let's talk about painting glory because
this is a very as you said this is
really a mode of arts story of his life
correct the directress but but it's told
through many different stages is that
right yeah no stages of life may be or
times I mean some events that are in the
movie are biographical is there are
things that really happen and some
others know is what he called you know
self fiction things that he wanted to
say that he never said things that he
wanted to do that he never did you know
he made that happen in the movie it's
almost like fulfilling a puzzle of your
life and putting pieces that were missed
at some point and you just start
thinking you know that are you only the
things that you have done or are you
also do dreams and so the movies is
pretty much about that it's about
looking back at a specific age he's 70
years old and I he said to me you know
there is a a moment in the life of
people in which there is only space for
the truth and so he just tries just to
look back and look for his truth and I
think he did a very beautiful movie that
actually connect with audiences
particularly all around the world it was
a beautiful experience we have a clip
here I believe this is where your
character is talking to mom his mom yeah
and it's it's a it's a very it's a
powerful scene let's take a look at this
clip
scene two mutual nervous you don't care
whoever do the service
on the fears knocking over a silly those
tiny knew no ICS pretty telling - OH
you eloquent
[Music]
[Music]
the fellows implementable circum so hey
I have to say I I have to say and I find
this to be true of French and Spanish I
find those languages so beautiful that I
find I'm almost drawn in more by that
language when I'm watching a scene it
feels really powerful because it feels
like music to me and obviously I English
doesn't feel that way to me you know
every every language is true it has its
own music and they actually makes you
even move in different ways if you make
a movie in Italy and I have done because
I speak Italian to you your hands start
moving immediately yeah it's true when
I'm in Italy I start to do that saying I
want the pizza pie and they're like you
know oh he's making fun of us and I'm
like no I'm not I'm just it's what
happens you know what I happen when I go
to Ireland I'm just angry all the time
[Laughter]
Australia oh yeah oh my god I just drank
so much to drink I am so excited for you
do you have are you prepared to go to
the Oscars do you are you nervous about
it or you just feel like I'm gonna go
and whatever happens happens
yeah yeah I'm you know I'm I am NOT the
favorite I am just going there to enjoy
a magnificent year of with my friend
Pedro almodóvar with a wonderful movie
the canet has I said to you before with
audiences all around the world we got a
bunch of forwards we are totally fine
I'm gonna have fun really great well we
are so happy for you been coming on my
show for many years and you're a
brilliant actor and I'm so thrilled for
you this is really exciting pain and
glory is in select theaters naturally
we'll all be watching the on San Antonio